Taste the rainbow [__] hello everyone
how are you guys all doing hope you guys
are having a wonderful day and today we
are finally back with episode 15 of
worthless to Wall Street I know it's
been a while um pretty much just because
my computer broke and then after my
computer broke I was flipping elijan on
the Main and I didn't have enough money
to throw 100 Mil over to my merch and
now I do so as you can see we have 100
Mil which is what we ended up with after
episode 14 roughly I don't have the
exact amount so we're just going with
100 mil this episode's going to be a
little different because I think for the
first half of it or so I will be
merching about with 50 mil and random
stuff and then 50 mil I will be setting
aside to merch a random item that I have
pretty much made my entire Bank off of
so I just kind of want to give you guys
a little idea as far as how much money I
can actually make in a short amount of
time with this random item now it is
going to be blurred out of the screen
I'm sure that's going to upset you all
very greatly but it has to happen
because
there's just if if I show the amount of
people that are going to watch this
video the item it'll never be good again
so there's no point in me showing you
because then it's not good anyways so
there's no point in knowing other than
just to know what it is like you can't
do anything with it if I were to show
you hope you guys understand that but we
are going to get into the flip so
starting with 100 Mil on the dot and uh
yeah let's see what we can make this
episode all right so here's the merch
that we are going to be doing the other
45 mil will go into the uh the random
item but we have 500 uh halfes ready to
buy if they all buy I'll be making an
insane amount of money cuz right now
there's really good margins on making
crystal Keys uh torture ornament kits
right now not too shabby I could
actually take out a couple of the fury
ones I might do some TOS of fire I'm not
entirely sure though they've been
dropping a ton over the last couple days
but I'm going to go do the random merch
now and hopefully we can get some of the
stuff to buy all right well my secret
item is bought so I'm going to show you
guys now what price that is bought for
as you can see right there I'm going to
collect them now so I'm going to end
this clip and also as you can see a
torture ornament C bought for 10.6 I
believe I can sell this on for
$1299 and we'll go with that hopefully
we'll be able to sell that on that's
actually like 600k no 700k profit and
almost all the tooth and Loof house have
bought so I will probably put those
together before I go to class and then
sell them on well class got canceled
came back and torchure ornament cast
sold on which is pretty cool so that
means we can keep merching these
hopefully for the price that they are
currently at but I'm going to up it just
a little bit to 10605 but as also as you
can see I was able to buy all of the
tooth and loop paths so hopefully the
margins with the crystal keys are still
there I'm going to make those all into
Keys here in a second all right so as
you guys can see two of my torture
ornament kits have bought I'm going to
go list them up for 11299 K and
hopefully well we'll go
11199 hopefully they can sell them for
that that would mean we'd make about a
mill on total on those got to relist my
uh my secret item because the price of
them has have dropped all right so
assuming my secret item has bought and
will sell for this price that would mean
I'd only be making
around like 300 to 400k it's not a whole
lot um it's something though and I now
know that there's even bigger margins on
this item so I'm going to go and buy
more on my main or maybe even on this
account if I can scrap together enough
money actually I have no money oh no
barely barely um as you can see we have
517 Crystal Keys done going going to cut
this real quick all right so as you can
see this should be blocked off up here
but we were able to buy all of these
Crystal keys for a total of 17 point
pretty much 18 mil on the dot and give
me one second all right so as you know
we were able to merge the first this one
right here that's kind of outlined this
one right here so this merch was the
secret item and we were able to merch
that for 400k and then we were able to
merch it again for 1.4 mil so we're up
1.8 m on the secret items I think I'm
going to have to blur everything out for
the most part these torch ornament kits
aren't selling so I'm going to have to
figure out a price to sell these on that
and uh yeah all right so we sold off for
torch ornament kits for 10 point or yeah
10.9 mil I don't know what I bought them
for probably around 10.6 is I made a
little bit of money off of that h no not
even 10.6 I honestly think I made more I
could have made around a mil all right
so the secret item just finish buying we
will now go and flip these and uh yeah
see how it goes as you can see we have
the uh the [__] secret item merching
they are selling or it or they I don't
know is it more than one thing who knows
it's selling for 61.8 mil and I bought
it for 60 so you know we could make 1.8
mil on this merch pretty sick right by
the way just so you guys know where we
are
at uh started doing this this morning
and we are pretty much at 105 mil so we
made 5 mil today pretty lit um probably
end off this video today's Friday or the
Friday night so we'll probably end it on
Saturday or Sunday we'll end up making
10 to 15 mil hopefully all right so we
bought the secret item overnight and uh
not all of them bought so we were able
to buy them for 29 mil and we're listing
them now up for
32.3 uh so yeah I have a little bit of
money we're buying some more of the
secret item and then I I'll do I'll do
some side flips so uh you guys can
actually have something to watch all
right boys T boys um tons of stuff has
tons of stuff have bought so we got two
Eternal crystals for 3.45 S I believe I
can sell them on for
3547 so make about 90k on that um
nothing too much 90k on each
3547 I did have to buy the margin so I'm
really only
making like [__] 90k in general but
I'll be able to flip these continuously
um Infinity boots for
1720 I believe I can sell these on for
probably 1 GP below Med is what I got
them for before so uh 50k on each one of
those so that's a 300K cuz I already had
to buy the margin and the rainar seeds
actually have a huge margin right now at
uh 27.3 no that was Snap Dragons All
right so as you can see with ranard
there was actually a 1.5k margin which
means if it's still around I can make
300K off of all these and combined the
secret item has bought off for 48 mil I
have to go and yeah just figure out the
price again cuz I wasn't able to sell
off all of the other offer yet so I kind
to have a ton of them right now all
right boys so pretty much everything's
done selling the ranar seeds are done
torch ornaments are done Infinity boots
are done and the secret item is pretty
much done I cannot show you how close it
is or how much of it's sold because you
know you guys would figure it out and
there we go so look at that [__] [__]
look at that [__]
110.3 mil so we're up 10.3 mil since the
start of this episode some good [__]
right all right so about to go grab
something to eat but three of the
tyrannical rings have bought there's
actually decent margins on these I can
sell these on for $ 4989 which means we
make about 170k on two of them I had to
buy the margin for one of them so$ 4989
we'll end up making about 350k off of
this merch there we go our secret item
has sold off I don't know why I'm
talking like that that was such a weird
voice anyways secret item sold off we
got 1.8 mil uh I'm going to bed but I'm
going to buy it again so all right here
we are so we got a torture ornament kit
to buy we also got all of the Ring of
sufferings to sell on for 6913 which is
actually a pretty good profit
considering we bought them all for about
150k less than that I think exactly 150k
so that's some good [__] we made
probably around I don't even know what
the [__] did we make on that like 600k
is um one of the tyrannical rings have
sold that's kind of a problem cuz these
things are not selling this is it's
actually been a while since I made the
last clip so all right so as you can see
we were able to buy another torture
ornament kit none of these have sold on
yet so I'm going to lower the price just
because we were able to get two and not
sell on any yet so I'm going to go 106
80 okay drop down GP and we'll be making
about 1.1 mil on that um I'm going to go
back and do the uh secret merch for a
while cuz we got a lot of money stocked
up so why not I'm also going to buy a
tyrannical ring so I can know what price
sell these bad boys 4 and uh go from
there back again and look at that so
torture kit and tyrannical Rings both
sold on we will collect those now and
yeah so 52 mil here then I have 60 mil
in my secret item so we're up to 112 mil
all right what is going on boys and
girls um finally got done with the
secret merch basically I put in about
109.5 mil or 110 milish into this merch
and got got 112.5 back as you can see so
obviously made a little bit of money on
that going to do some more stuff today
and this probably be the last day that I
uh do stuff for this video so here we go
15.8 is somewhere around there yeah
we're getting up there all right so just
did a quick flip merch over here we were
buying these I think I bought it for
10.35 so I flipped it for a 400k profit
um the heavy ballistas have a 140k
margin so I've been able to buy three
which means I'd make 280 if they all
sold I'm going to go ahead and buy two
more since I have the money to do so now
and uh yeah we'll go from there just
woke up from a nap and a little bit of
studying so armadel godsword ornament
cast bought probably going to lower the
price on these around
6.95 milish so I'll be making 400k off
of both of those Dragon Defender
ornament kits are two have bought for
4.22 mil I'll be setting those up for
4.5 so that'll be a total of about 575k
merch and the zamrock god sword ornament
kit I'm going to list up for 3 mil which
if it does sell would be an 800k merch
so these kits are uh doing really good
for me right now holy [__] boys just got
back from doing a little bit of studying
as you can see we were able to sell off
one of the zrod godsword kits for 2984 I
believe it was yeah 2984 so that's
insane we got two more so we're going to
list them both up for that I'm going to
buy another few just cuz I can all right
so as I was saying we're going to list
these up for 2984 I don't know if I
actually said that or not but I meant to
and we'll be making about 700k on both
of those one more Dragon Defender kit
bought for 4.2 and we were able to sell
on both these for
4.47 so uh you know not not too bad
going nothing too bad going on there I'm
going to list this one up pretty high
just because it's probably going to sell
overnight so I'm hoping we can throw it
up there pretty far and see what happens
with that and then I'm probably also
going to drop in a low ball offer just
because I'm not entirely sure on the
prices right now so I don't really want
to overpay for anything like this so I
think I'm just going to go right over
the med price and we'll go with that so
hopefully some of this stuff can buy I
know I don't have all of my GP at work
here but I got all my slots so you know
it is what it is and uh we'll go from
there all right so as you can see all
the things we have selling except these
armadel God Sword ornament kits have
sold on so we're going to collect all of
this and I think that's where we're
going to add off the video so I kind of
show you guys where we are we'll be able
to sell these on for 13 mil at least so
add that on to whatever cash check we
have so 106 mil + 13 mil means that we
are at 119 mil after this episode all
right so we are ending off the video
here with 106.3 mil and two armadel
godsword ornament kits which uh yeah
have no value right now but they're 13
mil combined so we are ending at 119.5
is MIL so that's a lot of progress for
one video um if you guys are wondering
why I did those uh I almost said the
item if you guys are wondering why I did
the uh the secret item it's just to show
you guys how much money you can make
merching in a short amount of time if
you know the right items I'm not going
to do it anymore but it just something
cool that I thought I could show you
guys so uh yeah if you guys enjoyed the
video feel free to hit the like button
if you guys have anything you want me to
approve upon or anything you want to say
to me comments down below as your friend
um if you guys want to contact me in
game join 07 helpers and uh yeah hope
you guys enjoyed the video um feel free
to hit that sub button show me a little
bit of support So nonetheless with that
being said hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace s everything is
going
[Music]